[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le les bandes
chassé par la rue il y a un an
l'ancien premier ministre saad hariri
est de nouveau désigné à ce poste pour
sortir le pays d'une terrible crise
économique et sociale
alors comment démarre le nouveau mandat
de saad hariri
le 22 octobre le président libanais
michel aoun le charge de former un
gouvernement
une décision accueillie avec scepticisme
par une partie des libanais qui
continuent de manifester
hariri tente d'apaiser les tensions tant
bien que mal et promet de mener
rapidement des réformes
ces futures réformes font partie de
l'initiative française proposée par
emmanuel macron en visite au liban le
président français a exigé du
gouvernement libanais qu'il met en place
une série de mesures économiques et
politiques en échange de l'aide
financière internationale
cependant ce plan risque de bouleverser
les positions du hezbollah sur
l'échiquier politique libanais le parti
chiite cherche donc à empêcher à tout
prix sa réalisation
pourtant compte tenu de la pression des
etats-unis qui menacent que les bancs de
nouvelles sanctions le hesbollah peut-il
vraiment remporter la partie
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le système politique libanais
c'est le great le pacte national de 1943
qui est toujours en vigueur représentant
un compromis fixant une répartition
confessionnelle des fonctions publiques
et est le président de la république est
ainsi forcément chrétien maronite le
premier ministre un musulman sunnite
le président de la chambre des députés
est forcément toujours un musulman
chiite
les sièges du parlement sont aussi
divisée entre les communautés
religieuses sur les 128 sièges 64 sont
destinés aux confessions chrétiennes
l'autre moitié se partage entre les
différentes branches de l'islam 27
sièges pour les sunnites 27 pour les
chiites
10 pour tous les autres aujourd'hui
pourtant toutes ces confessions sont
mélangés dans deux alliances adverse
structurée autour de l'idéologie
politique l'alliance du 8 mars est celle
du 14 mars
forte de 55 sièges sur 128 cette
dernière est formellement dirigé par le
premier ministre actuel saad hariri
épreuve l'amitié avec l'arabie saoudite
et les etats unis tout en critiquant
l'iran et la syrie pour l'alliance du 8
mars
en revanche c'est tout le contraire
détenant la majorité de 65 sièges
elle entretient des relations étroites
avec l'iran et soutient le président
syrien bachar el-assad une ligne
politique qui irrite washington et ses
alliés du golfe
un an après avoir démissionné sous la
pression de la rue saad hariri est de
nouveau nommé premier ministre
la raison en est simple c'est le seul
homme de compromis figures politiques
sunnites possédant une solide expérience
est issu du pouvoir et la range les
principales forces politiques du pays
néanmoins son retour sur le devant de la
scène suscite la colère et le
scepticisme d'une partie de la
population
hariri rassure les réformes en
profondeur vont être menées et le
gouvernement sera formé au plus vite
ces changements sont en effet une
exigence de la france on visite à
beyrouth dévasté par une terrible
explosion
dans le port de la ville emmanuel macron
promet une aide financière
internationale
en échange de réformes au pays du cèdre
pourtant le plan du chef de l'état
français est vue d'un mauvais oeil par
une partie des forces politiques
libanaises dont le hezbollah car si ce
plan est mis en oeuvre il l'affaiblir a
considérablement l'influencent politique
du parti chiite le hezbollah fait donc
tout pour le torpille cependant va-t-il
et parvenir compte tenu de la pression
croissante des etats-unis qui menacent
le hesbollah de nouvelles sanctions
comment la nomination de hariri
va-t-elle modifier l'échiquier politique
du liban
quels défis se posent devant le nouveau
premier ministre
enfin quels sont les intérêts de la
france au liban
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons daniel meyer chercheur et
enseignant à sciences po grenoble
chargée de cours à l'université de
genève et auteur de l'ouvragé liban
pouvoir identité et conflits monsieur
meyer bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord pourquoi hariri pour la
quatrième fois il n'y avait pas d'autre
candidat acceptable pour tous c'est une
bonne question en réalité la rue elle
est très divisée je dirais qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on l'a on la voit depuis
l'europe
et depuis l'extérieur de façon assez
assez monolithique
or en réalité elle est largement
structuré par des groupes
contradictoires d'un côté évidemment le
mouvement révolutionnaire le mouvement
social du 19 du 17 octobre 2019 et de
l'autre côté
donc la myriade de groupes politiques
qui ont leur clientèle habituelle et je
dirais qu'ils ont récupéré avec cette
crise économique terrible qui frappe le
liban qui ont récupéré donc leur leur
électorat
puisque ce sont eux qui sont à même dans
le fond de proposer des solutions de
proposer aussi des moyens financiers
alors à leurs électeurs
une crise économique et sociale forte
majeur pensez vous que hariri ce sera à
la hauteur
c'est une bonne question aussi mais là
par contre j'y crois pas j'y crois pas
vraiment est-ce qu'il va réussir dans le
fond à sortir le liban du gouffre c'est
dans le meilleur des cas et trouvera oui
il trouvera un moyen de rassurer les
bailleurs de fonds c'est c'est possible
disons de façon à ce qu'ils
réinvestissent au liban avec un plan de
soutien massif
celui qui a été promis depuis longtemps
maintenant à coutances de paris en 2010
8 e
mais toutes les projections et c'est ça
le problème les projections économiques
même les plus optimistes ne voit guère
le bout du tunnel
le pays est beaucoup trop endettés le
secteur bancaire est gangréné par des
logiques clientélistes et surtout les
acteurs politiques devant faire des
réformes sont largement et très peu
enclin à lâcher leurs prébendes
entretenant la confusion entre les biens
publics et privés
une sorte de cocktail qui leur a permis
rappelons le de devenir les acteurs
surpuissant qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
monsieur meyer justement pensez-vous que
hariri réussira à sortir le liban du
gouffre économique et social où il se
trouve actuellement en fait arrivé est
un homme qui qui a effectivement un
carnet d adresses important il peut
avoir le soutien du fmi
il peut y avoir des pressions politiques
sur un acteur comme le fmi
mais le problème c'est que le secteur
bancaire lui-même ne suis pas forcément
les enfin ne suis même pas du tout où
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les demandes du fmi
et ses essais donc que tout à fait
exclue pour l'instant
face à l'absence j'irai de toute réforme
de l'enclenchement de toute réforme
qu'il y est
je dirais un soutien financier qui plus
est un programme du fmi justement saad
hariri promet aussi de réformer le
secteur bancaire du pays mais on va y
revenir dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission merci encore pour cette
analyse nous reviendrons également vers
vous pour plus de détails sur la
question merci encore quatrième
tentative pour saad hariri trois fois
désigné premier ministre du liban qu il
vient d'être une nouvelle fois chargée
par le président du pays michel aoun de
former un gouvernement
une tâche qu'il accepte avec
enthousiasme
je suis déterminé à travailler à mettre
fin à l effondrement qui menacent notre
économie notre société et notre sécurité
ironie du sort il ya près d'un an saad
hariri démissionné sous la pression de
la rue comment s'est-il de nouveau
retrouvé sur le siège du premier
ministre le fait est que après le départ
de saad hariri la situation au liban ne
s'est pas améliorée loin de là décembre
2019 le successeur de hariri est désigné
il s'appelle hassan diab
se présentant comme un indépendant il
doit pourtant sa nomination à l'appui du
hezbollah et de ses alliés et diamants
tient compte en formant son cabinet les
ministres du camp pro iranien et
occupent les postes-clés
une première dans l'histoire du pays une
composition qui remet de l'huile sur le
feu des protestations et la colère monte
à mesure que la situation économique se
détériore inflation chômage pauvreté
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge le 4
août 2020 une double explosion retentit
dans le port de beyrouth elle ravage une
grande partie de la capitale libanaise
et fait au moins 190 morts et plus de
6000 blessés des centaines de milliers
d'habitants se retrouvent sans abri la
négligence des autorités du port miné
par la corruption et rapidement invoqué
afin d'expliquer pourquoi les deux mille
sept cent cinquante tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium ont été laissés à l'abandon
durant six ans c'est l'événement de trop
le drame relance la contestation
populaire qui accusent la classe
politique d'être responsable de l'
explosion dévastatrice
sous pression de la rue
gouvernement de hassan diab fait ses
valises afin d'éviter l'aggravation de
la crise les principales forces
politiques du pays s'entendent sur le
remplaçant mustapha adib professeur
d'université est nommé ambassadeur en
allemagne en 2013 après sa désignation
formelle par le président le nouveau
premier ministre s'engage fin août à
former un an temps record une équipe
ministérielle afin de réaliser au plus
vite les réformes tant attendues
pourtant mustapha a dit bhl se retrouve
très vite face à l'impossibilité de
former un gouvernement et jette l'épongé
la raison de ma démission c'est que les
blocs politiques n'ont pas rempli ma
condition
ils n'ont pas renoncé à politiser le
processus de formation du gouvernement
en l'absence d'autres candidats le
président du pays se tournent de nouveau
vers saad hariri
sa candidature est soutenue par une
majorité de 65 députés pourtant ce
compromis est plus que fragile car même
dans son propre bloc politique celui du
14 mars le plus grande partie chrétien
refusent de soutenir la nomination de
hariri doutant de la viabilité de son
gouvernement dans le bloc pro-iranien
celui du 8 mars tout n'est pas si simple
non plus sa plus puissante force
politique le courant patriotique libre
tourne lui aussi le doaré riz préférant
un technocrate à un homme politique
le hezbollah lui joue la neutralité
alors que le principal parti chiite amal
apporte son soutien à saad hariri en
cherchant à avoir un certain poids dans
le futur gouvernement
du côté de la population libanaise la
candidature d'hariri est accueillie
assez froidement le 22 octobre le jour
de sa nomination des manifestations sont
organisées un peu partout à beyrouth
beaucoup moins nombreux qu'en 2019 les
libanais se montre néanmoins dubitatifs
quant à la capacité du gouvernement
hariri à réaliser les changements tant
attendue car la période sombre que le
pays traverse actuellement est qualifié
par la presse locale de pire crise dans
l'histoire du pays depuis son
indépendance
le taux de chômage atteint un niveau
record 30 % de la population active soit
150 mille personnes qui sont à la
recherche d'un emploi depuis le début
2020 la monnaie nationale a perdu 80% de
sa valeur face au dollar et les prix ont
plus que doublé
conscient de la gravité de la situation
saad hariri compte d'abord former un
nouveau gouvernement
celui ci serait composé d'experts non
affiliés à des partis politiques
ce n'est qu'ensuite qui promet de lancer
des réformes économiques financières et
administratives
tout d'abord arrêts et entend relancer
le dialogue avec le fmi afin d'obtenir
le plus vite possible une aide
financière audit indépendant de la
banque centrale changement du personnel
de la politique financière toutes les
conditions du futur créanciers sont
acceptés davance la lutte contre la
corruption serait l'autre priorité du
gouvernement un mois après la formation
du cabinet une commission nationale anti
corruption devrait voir le jour
ensuite le nouveau gouvernement va
développer de toute urgence son plan
d'action pour lutter contre le coc vie
19 l'autre défi qui ne peut plus
attendre et la reconstruction du port de
beyrouth une enquête indépendante sera
également lancée sur la cause de
l'explosion
côté politique le nouveau premier
ministre compte organiser un scrutin
législatif anticipé pendant une période
d'un an à compter de la formation du
cabinet la loi électorale sera réformé
avec une participation active de la
société civile assurer l'indépendance de
l'autorité judiciaire serait l'autre
mission du futur gouvernement
pour cela une loi spéciale sera
introduite au parlement selon al jazeera
toutes ces mesures font partie de la
feuille de route française que le
nouveau premier ministre s'est engagé à
appliquer quel est donc le rôle de paris
dans la crise libanaise quels défis se
dressent devant la diplomatie libanaise
dans leurs relations avec les pays
voisins
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
figure de compromis entre les
différentes forces politiques saad
hariri promet des réformes sans
précédent
cependant pourrait-il tenir ses
promesses compte tenu de son bilan assez
modeste à ce poste qu'il a déjà occupé à
trois reprises avant de se lancer en
politique
saad hariri dirige une entreprise
familiale spécialisée dans la
construction le groupe saudi oger ils
les rites de son père rafic hariri un
des hommes politiques les plus influents
du pays
ce dernier dirige le gouvernement
libanais de 1992 à 1998 puis de 2000 à
2004 et se fait connaître par sa ligne
politique clairement anti syrienne en
2005 rafic hariri tué dans un attentat à
la bombe perpétré en plein coeur de
beyrouth
cet acte déclenché la révolution du
cèdre des manifestations de masse contre
la présence des troupes syriennes dans
le pays sur fond de montée du sentiment
anti syrien saad hariri remporte les
élections législatives avec le parti de
son père le courant du futur
néanmoins par manque d'expérience il
doit laisser le poste de premier
ministre à l'ami d'enfance de son père
fuad signora après quatre ans à la tête
du pays son bilan est plutôt positif
la croissance économique est au rendez
vous tandis que la reconstruction du
pays avance petit à petit fort de ses
succès le courant du futur en porte en
2009 une nouvelle fois les élections
législatives
or cette fois saad hariri aspire lui
même au siège de premier ministre à la
demande du président libanais michel
sleimane il forme son gouvernement qui
comprend la quasi totalité de
l'échiquier politique libanais hezbollah
compris pourtant le cabinet ne tient pas
longtemps
en 2010 il durcit sa ligne politique à
l'égard de la syrie
l'accusant d'être derrière le meurtre de
son père en réponse les 11 ministres de
la coalition cros syrienne claque la
porte
le cabinet est donc dissous pourtant
afin d'éviter la vacance du pouvoir
hariri occupe le poste de premier
ministre jusqu'à la formation du nouveau
gouvernement en juin 2011
mais c'est sans compter sur la crise
syrienne qui commence à prendre de
l'ampleur et divise profondément le
liban entre partisans de damas et ses
opposants
prétextant des raisons de sécurité saad
hariri quittent le pays s installe en
arabie saoudite puis en france au liban
les troubles ne font que commencer
face aux désaccords sur le mode de
scrutin et aux tensions liées à la
guerre en syrie les députés libanais
reporte la tenue des élections
législatives prévues pour 2013 en mai
le mandat du président du pays expire
les tentatives d'élire un nouveau chef
d'état subissent un échec
le parlement n'y parvint pas faute
d'obtenir la majorité requise la
situation bouge en 2016 suite au retour
de saad hariri dans le pays
toujours leader du plus puissant parti
politique
il annonce son soutien à la candidature
de michel aoun au poste de président du
pays
en échange le parti politique daoud
soutient la candidature de hariri au
poste de premier ministre hariri
présente son nouveau cabinet fin 2016
tout semble bien parti hariri réussi à
trouver un équilibre entre les
différentes forces politiques libanaises
cela lui permet de négocier une nouvelle
loi électorale permettant au pays de
tenir ses premières élections
législatives depuis 2009
cependant en novembre 2017
le liban connaît un épisode inouï depuis
l'arabie saoudite où saad hariri était
parti passer ses vacances
il annonce sa démission une déclaration
faite dans des circonstances si vagues
que la communauté internationale
commence à s'inquiéter et à se demander
si ryad ne détient pas de force hariri
après une médiation de la france
hariri regagne finalement le liban et
continuent à exercer ces fonctions
pourtant cette démarche lui coûte des
points politiques en interne en mai 2018
son parti le courant du futur essuie un
revers cuisant aux élections
législatives et perd un tiers de ses
députés au parlement
néanmoins il conserve son statut du
leader de la principale force sunnite ce
qui permet au président de le charger de
former un gouvernement
ce n'est qu'à la fin janvier 2019 que
les négociations aboutissent le nouveau
cabinet à majorité prg aux iraniens
voient le jour
pourtant sur fond de bruits politiques à
répétition le pays s'enlise peu à peu
dans une profonde crise socio-économique
la dette publique s'envole et atteint
150% du pib
l'étincelle qui met le feu aux poudres
était la nouvelle taxe whatsapp
introduite par le gouvernement en
octobre 2019 afin de renflouer les
caisses de l'état
en signe de protestation des dizaines de
milliers de manifestants descendre dans
la rue réclamant le renouvellement de
toute la classe dirigeante jugé
corrompue et incompétente
face à la contestation le gouvernement
recule
il renonce à la taxe mais la
mobilisation ne fait que prendre de
l'ampleur face à la colère populaire
saad hariri et son gouvernement
démissionne en ce moment de la crise la
communauté internationale est au chevet
du liban depuis trois mois cet effort
des d'international est animée par
emmanuel macron en personne le président
français a fait du liban sa priorité
diplomatique après l'explosion à
beyrouth
début août ils seront sur les lieux et
promet de mobiliser le soutien
international en urgence promesse tenue
l'élysée convoque une conférence
internationale et rassemble 250 millions
d'euros destiné aux pays dévasté
néanmoins l'engagement français dépasse
le cadre humanitaire car emmanuel macron
n'hésite pas à exiger du liban des
réformes globales
début septembre il donne au premier
ministre moustapha a dit qui vient
d'être à peine investi 15 jours pour
former un cabinet viable ce n'est donc
pas une carte blanche qui est donné
aujourd'hui ou un chèque en blanc
bien au contraire c'est une fois encore
une exigence avec un rendez vous dont
six à huit semaines
un soutien aux allures d'ultimatum
si et seulement si ces conditions sont
respectées paris organisera une nouvelle
conférence internationale dead
humanitaire au liban de plus ce plan
français ouvrirait à beyrouth l'accès à
des milliards de dollars d'aidé
économique bloqué jusque là par le fmi
nous sommes prêts à redoubler d'efforts
cependant nous avons besoin que toutes
les institutions se réunissent déterminé
à mener à bien les réformes
indispensables
pourtant quelques semaines plus tard
mustapha adib se retrouve face à
l'impossibilité de rassembler les
principaux partis pour former un
gouvernement
il démissionne provoquant la colère des
manuels macron qui impute cet échec au
hezbollah
le hezbollah ne doit pas se croire plus
fort qu'il ne l'est et c'est à lui de
démontrer qu'ils respectent les libanais
dans leur ensemble ils à ces derniers
jours
clairement montré le contraire
effectivement l'intransigeance du
hezbollah est le principal obstacle au
consensus le parti refuse de céder le
contrôle d
ministère traditionnellement chi c'est
pourtant la demande clé de l'initiative
française
cependant le mouvement chiite a sa
propre explication
l'administration américaine est
directement responsable de l'obstruction
des efforts en vue de former le
gouvernement libanais le hezbollah
accuse donc washington de profiter de la
transition politique pour miner ses
positions il est vrai que la pression
américaine sur le mouvement chiite ne
cesse de croître
en voici les raisons en septembre la
maison blanche annonce deux volets de
sanctions contre le hezbollah
les membres de partis alliés sont même
ciblé pour la première fois c'est eto'o
de sanctions ne cesse d'ailleurs de se
resserrer depuis 2010 est par exemple
les etats-unis menacent de sanctions et
de privation d'accès au dollar toutes
les banques libanaises qui ne fermerait
pas les comptes des membres du hezbollah
et des organisations affiliées à
l'origine de cette pression la grande
proximité entre le hezbollah et l'iran
ennemi juré de l'administration trump et
c'est assez inhabituel mais cette fois
le hesbollah n'ose pas le ton à la place
au contraire il tente l'apaisement et
fait même un geste symbolique en effet
dès octobre c'est l'aval du hezbollah
qui ouvre la voie à des pourparlers
historique entre le liban et israël
une première depuis 30 ans l'enjeu est
de régler leur différend territorial
maritime sous les auspices de washington
et de l'onu israël parle d' un pas vers
la paix en élan qui suscite aussi l'
enthousiasme de la maison blanche celle
ci ne comptant pas s'arrêter aux accords
entre israël le bahreïn et les émirats
arabes unis selon la presse arabe le
hesbollah chercherait avant tout à
éviter de nouvelles sanctions
en outre le liban est désormais dirigé
par l'ancien nouveau premier ministre
saad hariri qui promet des concessions
au parti chiite au sujet de
portefeuilles clés pourtant sa priorité
reste avant tout le plan français le
temps presse et c'est la seule et
dernière chance pour notre pays bien
aimé la france tiendra-t-elle toutes ses
promesses saad hariri
sera-t-il à la hauteur du rôle que
l'élite politique et religieuse des
balaises lui a confiée
quels sont les autres acteurs impliqués
dans cette mosaïque
internationale pour y voir plus clair
nous revenons vers daniel meyer
chercheur et enseignant à sciences po
grenoble chargée de cours à l'université
de genève
monsieur meyer parlons géopolitique
maintenant les exigences des manuels
macro envers le liban sont est le fruit
d'une vision rationnelle de la situation
ou constituent-elles plutôt une
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
du pays du cèdre
sans aucun doute je pense qu'elles sont
davantage une ingérence dans la façon
dont elles ont été amenées à la manière
si vous voulez d'un professeur faisant
la leçon à de mauvais élève se souvient
certaines interpellations en ce sens est
évidemment de l'attitude de d'élèves
plutôt mauvais du reste de la peintre la
classe politique libanaise qui s'était
rendu à la rencontre du président
français lorsqu'il était venu au mois de
septembre mais elles sont aussi apparus
en fait comme une sorte de bouffée d'air
pour la société libanaise dans son
combat pour demander un changement de
cap aux leaders politiques de ce point
de vue donc c'est un c'est un élément je
dirais positif par contre l'elysée at il
les moyens de cette politique
ça c'est toute la question je pense
aujourd'hui et malgré tout les seins les
phrases décisive du président français
sur le terrain jusqu'à maintenant bien
peu de réalisations concrètes
hariri est il en mesure de composer donc
entre la france l'arabie saoudite
téhéran et les états unis est il assez
habile oui c'est possible je pense que
on le disait antérieurement c'est un
homme qui a un carnet d'adressés
important c'est un homme influent il
assure la couverture sunnite est donc en
fait comme toujours et on l'a vu déjà
par le passé donc rien de nouveau sous
le soleil
ce sera évidemment un grand écart ce
sera dans des gares entre entre je
dirais les pays rivaux de la région et
leur soutien
globo l'arrivée toutefois d'une nouvelle
administration à washington est
susceptible de rendre l'arabie saoudite
moins intransigeante et l'iran peut-être
plus accommodant ça reste à confirmer
évidemment cela met un terme en tout cas
c'est un peu facilité la tâche du
premier ministre enfin concernant les
négociations sur les frontières
maritimes entre israël et le liban pour
tel-aviv c'est un pas vers la paix le
les banques pour at-il selon vous
devenir le cinquième pays à conclure un
traité de paix avec israël
en fait non je ne crois pas en tout cas
pas à ce stade et dans ce contexte le
contexte qui est celui d'une
intransigeance israélien l'égard de deux
de la question palestinienne et enfin le
contexte c'est aussi la présence du
réseau là dont on peut rappeler qu'une
des raisons d'être et justement
l'existence de son ennemi éternel un
l'israël
mais on doit rappeler peut-être une
chose c'est que les discussions
techniques existent depuis longtemps
entre israël et le liban sur la
frontière terrestre et ce depuis 2007 et
donc ces discussions sur la frontière
maritime peuvent durer assez longtemps
et du reste il n'ya que l'envoyé
américain qui a dit qu'il fallait que ce
soit liquidée en quelques mois
en réalité ça ne figure dans aucun
accord la durée de ces négociations
donc elles peuvent durer assez longtemps
le fait est que l'exploitation des
espaces maritimes
une sorte de nécessité économique pour
le liban est donc ça serait évidemment
avantageuse d'arriver à une entente
assez rapidement avec israël sur ce
point mais cette entente ne voudra en
aucun cas dire tout comme les
précédentes entente sur des tracés de la
frontière terrestre savent vraiment pas
du tout dire qu on est dans une logique
de faire la paix avec avec israël merci
beaucoup monsieur meyer je rappelle
daniel meyer chercheur et enseignant à
sciences po grenoble chargée de cours à
l'université de genève et auteur de
l'ouvragé liban pouvoir identité et
conflits étaient là aujourd'hui avec
nous merci encore pour votre éclairage
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]